is there a way out of depression and
anxiety
find out on this episode of led live
exposing darkness welcome everyone to
another episode of led live we are glad
to have our guests
back again for this episode dr and mrs
heldzinger
and danique and thank you guys for
joining us today
to talk about depression and anxiety and
recovering from that because
as we talked about and kind of ended the
last episode we ended it on the note
of hope that there is hope for people
who have depression
and anxiety and they can recover from
that so thank you for joining us today
so for those who are watching the first
time you are
a medical doctor yes and primarily
general practice or family medicine but
you're also board certified in lifestyle
medicine yes
okay and mrs helzinger
by the time this comes out you will have
graduated right right
with a degree in clinical mental health
counseling
okay awesome and denis used to volunteer
for our ministry and
you're here as both a product
of some of the programs we're talking
about and
now going on the other side helping
people who have struggled from
depression anxiety
i had it myself went through the medley
depression anxiety recovery program at
therapy and
now i'm a small group facilitator for
the nedley depression anxiety recovery
program the
um community-based one yeah okay and we
love facilitating together
yeah it's a blessing yes so
somebody may have depression they may
have anxiety and they may be wondering
what do i do how do i get out of this
how do we start well i try to
when people come to me with these kind
of things they usually
have been to a doctor who has put them
on
a antidepressant medication okay that's
usually the first line treatment that
people
use is to go on antidepressant medicine
sure and then if they don't get better
the doses are adjusted or they
they add counseling and people get sent
off to a counselor
and that's usually what ends up
happening and if people don't respond
they get labeled as
a a non-responder maybe gets sent to a
psychiatrist who gives them higher doses
more drugs and that's usually the
the line of of treatment that goes on
and people get
very depressed and discouraged
particularly when you are
following the advice of your physician
you're doing what the psychiatrist is
saying
you're taking your medicine as
prescribed but you don't get anything
there's no it's not
it's not working so by the time they
come to you then and want to know is
there anything else that we can do
they they very uh you know without hope
and they don't feel like anything that
you're going to suggest
is going to uh to help them and i should
mention that you know depression is no
joke i think that
there you know in the last couple of
years maybe last two years or so
mostly young people on social media have
started coming out saying you know i
struggle with this and that
and it's become more acceptable to talk
about
but i had a friend recently tell me that
hey you know i struggle with mental
health and my family doesn't understand
you know they they don't understand they
think it's just a
small little thing and actually what's
interesting is when i was a kid i
actually also had depression as a kid 12
years old
and i went to see a psychiatrist he said
oh one session you're fine that was so
ridiculous i never went back there
obviously and eventually i went and
talked to
these like child therapists and i was
there for a couple of months
but you see how even people are in the
field sometimes don't understand
um and and so it's it's not a joke it's
as
serious as someone who has let's say a
broken leg
it's a serious someone who has cancer
can die from it because people die from
mental illness
because they commit suicide it's that
serious sometimes
it's very lethal right yeah well that's
the reason why
you know we recommend coming to this um
eight week program it's one night a week
you get all your materials
you know you have a variety of reading
materials this is cognitive behavior
therapy from a christian
point of view also dr neil nedley's
textbook
is the prescribed textbook which
i know of a girl who was suffering
severely from depression
and she couldn't afford um the
residential program which is in weimar
california
and she um there was no you know smaller
program nearby so she took this book
and started reading it and started doing
everything was in the book and she got
better
wow so it's like you know you can pay to
go into college or you can
learn from using youtube or whatever
you're you know researching yourself
looking for it so if you really want the
help and you can't afford it there
are cheaper alternatives such as this
book that can help yeah
well the the the good thing about this
and this is coming back to why i think
this program is better than any other
program
out there is the fact that this program
is designed to look for the cause you
see
now when you research uh the literature
out there and say what are the causes of
depression
you will get depressed because there's
hundreds of causes
okay and so people look at this and they
say how in the world
am i going to address all of these
things but
dr nelly has done significant research
on this and found that you can
categorize these causes into 10
categories
which he calls hit categories okay and
so and so
once you go through a a
a test that you can take before to see
where you fall and what are the
categories in your life that
you have a problem with and then you can
identify the areas in your life that
that you need help with and then uh what
you can do is this is not look at oh
here's a hundred
a list of a hundred things that causes
depression
you now can look at these are all ways
that i haven't tried before you see
there's
it's not just there's all these causes
these are different things that i
haven't tried to fix
so now you instead of making the person
feel hopeless
oh my look at all these causes of
depression on the world am i ever going
to get better
you can say there's a lot of things that
i haven't tried and if i try all these
things
things may happen and so this is a
comprehensive
approach so let me ask a question let's
say i take the test and
there's five things out of those ten and
then somebody else i know takes the test
and they get
five of the other things that are on the
list is the treatment gonna be
different for those people or is it
basically
it doesn't really matter which one's out
of the 10 or how many on the out of the
10 the treatment's going to be the same
because
you know there's there's it's addressing
all the root
causes this the program is designed to
address
all the root causes so whether you've
got this three
or four or you have that five or six it
doesn't really matter
we all can benefit from uh
dealing with loss now you may not have
loss in your life right now
but if you live long enough sure you're
gonna have to deal with loss okay
a spouse may die a parent may die you
might lose a job
whatever and so so you're gonna have to
so even though
that may not be a hit for you right now
you may have other hits because you're
at a different stage of your life
you you can still benefit from
learning all that is there to be learned
about a comprehensive approach where
you'd
where you address all the different hit
categories
and i have them i have them right here
this is from the workbook that we use in
the program
um and so it says here uh frontal lobe
category
uh live cell circuit so that like diet
exercise that kind of stuff circadian
rhythm you know
sleep cycle nutrition if you eat a bunch
of junk food all day long it's not going
to feed your brain very well
toxins can be like a mercury poisoning
or something like that which mainly
comes from
fish social slash inadequate coping
slash grief
addiction medical condition
developmental that's where you're
looking at
um you know a dysfunctional home
growing up abuse and then genetic
okay those are 10 categories and i i
just want to say that the
mental health hospital has its place you
know
if you or someone you know is feeling
very suicidal
it is important for them to go to a
place where they can be medically
supervised
and taken care of until they feel better
however
you know like with dr nedley's program
it's
it just gives us a lot of lifestyle
medicine alternatives it gives us
natural ways of treating the same thing
instead of just
you know taking all those drugs all
those meds so that you know the mind is
not really able to process
whatever you're going through you know
if you're suffering from a loss or
you know a very very difficult situation
yes the medicine that is on short-term
basis
only dr nedley and my husband um you
know
give that medicine on short-term basic
basis only with the goal of coming off
that medicine
at the longest for a year six months to
a year but
unfortunately you know we see many many
people that are
for 10 15 years 20 years sometimes on
those medicines but this program gives
you the alternatives
so that you can incorporate natural ways
of treating depression
anxiety and this it's also very good for
bipolar
yeah okay so it seems like i remember
recently getting a text message on my
phone or something that
now i mean the government and society
has recognized mental health as a big
enough issue there's a
like a quick number you can dial now
right i think it's like nine eight eight
or something
so here i mean suicidal issues you call
that you know 988 and you can get some
help immediately so that's that's good
yeah but unfortunately we live in a
society
that is uh you know and in our medical
system in general
uh is pharmaceutical driven there's
there's a drug for every ailment
and the doctor never runs out of drugs
you know if this one doesn't work i have
another one in the bag that i'm going to
give you
a side effect yeah so there's always
stuff so people have a
unrealistic expectation of what the
medications can do for you now i'm not a
person that say you don't prescribe no
medications
medications has its place and there's a
place for these things to be used
but it's more for the very severe
type cases okay and so and then again
also
with a plan of addressing all the other
causes
and with the idea that down the line in
the
pretty near future that i'm going to try
and wean this person off his medication
or at least have him on a much lower
dosage yes you bring up a good point and
and i've actually seen the same
approach from the naturalistic side
yes or we take something that's a
natural herb or a remedy or something
and treat it like it's a medication oh
you just need to take just take this tea
and you know
and you know it's all better which which
i agree
there's probably a place where it
probably helps but if it's like well you
need to relax or you're not sleeping
well then
why why are you not sleeping well it's
not that you just need this tea
we need to figure out why are you not
sleeping well why are you not relaxing
why do you have you know that anxiety
yeah so yeah and that's something that i
think really comes from
getting therapy um and again it's it's
um much less of a taboo nowadays to get
therapy i think
there's still for men i think it's still
harder to get into therapy it's because
it's the masculinity it's like
feeling weak and you know i've run into
many people
that had serious issues that would not
admit any of their issues and would just
not get therapy because they're like no
no um but that's yeah it's very helpful
i've had several years of therapy and
it's changed my life because
um you go back to the root you know you
fix the root
so like let's say you have diabetes type
and and you're extremely obese
and your diet consists of fried chicken
and coke then
it's probably not really going to help
you that much
to take medication for that but if you
say well let me change my lifestyle let
me eat
healthier and exercise then you can
very often reverse the diabetes and so
it's the same thing with
mental health that if you go back to the
root cause
and you know sometimes like it said here
um it could be
a a genetic hit you know but
um how many hits was it that if you're
under this number of hits that you
are depression free so like even if you
have a genetic hit it doesn't mean you
have to have depression
how much was it three uh anything more
than
three yeah is when you begin to qualify
right for a major depression episode
so even if you have a genetic hit or
developmental hit you can't change that
it doesn't mean you have to have
depression if you take care of the other
things
therapy and having a healthy lifestyle
right and i just want to say that
counseling is a gift
it's especially a christian counselor
that doesn't just look to themselves
or that you're looking inside yourself
for solutions but that you
are incorporating you're asking god
you're asking jesus to be the wonderful
counselor
and come into that counseling session
and that counselor is coming alongside
you and walking with you
supporting you through whatever you're
going through counseling is a gift
yeah even the bible talks about um
well for one it talks about listening
you know being
slow to anger and what is it talking
about uh
a lot about listening though and then
james yeah quick to listen
yeah quick to listen and also there's
verses that talk about you know a fool
doesn't take um yeah
so yeah so it's a god-given gift counsel
and listening
and i like that you brought up it's very
important you know to to understand that
just because somebody has mental health
it seems like there's a stigma with that
we're like no it's
demonic or it's something else no it's
an organ just like the rest of your body
and if you have
something wrong with your heart a
doctor's going to go in there and put a
stent in or whatever because there's
something wrong with that organ
and so getting to the root is very
important
and you sometimes you just need somebody
to talk to we live in a day and age
where hardly anybody is socializing
outside of
typing and there's all kinds of
misinterpretations i mean i could
send a text to my wife and because
there's no body language and inflection
she could take it the wrong way or
something you know
and so just having a person available
that can listen and give good counsel
and get to the root of this thing
is way more uh beneficial than
oh you're feeling depressed this will
make you happy i got a pill for that and
i just think that's the wrong courage
how it often happens in religion that i
really have an issue with
is just pray about it you know like why
are we treating mental health
differently from a physical illness
when like you said it's the brain it's
an organ we talked about in the last
episode that there's neural pathways
being made in our brain
and that we have to change it's not just
a philosophy an idea it's an actual
physical thing
um and and just to say we'll just pray
about or god fixes everything it's like
you have a broken arm no just pray about
it no you need to go to a doctor and get
it fixed you get a cast
but we see it as a as a as a weakness
yeah because we feel that we're not in
control of our life
and so therefore it's different than
just the broken arm but you're right
it's you can't just pray for the broken
arm and hope that you
got to do something and so you have to
do something for the brain as well
well and i believe that god works
together
in that situation with the physician a
christian or
you know with your physician or god is
working together with
that counseling and we have seen the
power of god
working in this needly depression
anxiety recovery program
you know and anyway it's just really
powerful
so i want to start to walk through our
audience like
they're they they want to recover from
this okay
so i i'm realizing you know i'm taking
the medication i'm depressed
nothing's working i keep going to my
doctor they keep upping my dose
it's not working so i see somebody like
you and
you have me go through this this test it
identifies these markers
now what what kind of things am i going
to start to encounter on my
road to recovery what does that process
look like
and then let's let's hopefully we'll get
to
like stories or testimonies of people
who have
had this work in their life well there's
obviously
different kinds of of people out there
there are people that
are mildly depressed and they they
recognize their situation
they want to help and they're willing to
help themselves and they are
self-driven so many of those people can
pick up
the tools and they can on their own
self-motivate it
go through the program and do the things
themselves and implement all the changes
and they do well it's like somebody that
wants to lose weight they implement
the principles and they lose weight and
others have to go to a program where
there's other people that support them
and that help them and that they can
help with
each other to get better and then
there's people that need to be admitted
they need a boot camp they need to be in
an in a residential
program because they need somebody to
take them by the hand and to not just
just encourage them but to actually take
them there
okay walk and so somebody that's a
little bit more of a stronger hand so
you need to lay that out and see where
your patient is
and what you can do for them and then go
from there as you implement all these
things okay
so there is an online program available
from dr nedleyhealthsolutions.com
there is an online program available but
the best thing to do
is to go onto the website
nedleydepressionthewayout.com okay
um no it's nedley depression recovery
there's two different websites
one is depressionrecovery.com
that is for the small program then
there's depressionthewayout.com
and that one is for the residential
program
and so look for a small program near you
that is the number one thing dr nedley
himself told me
that little program is the biggest bang
for your buck because
um it's almost as successful as the
residential program
and there might be a program near you
yeah so you're
identifying people where they're at when
they come to you and then you're saying
you know
you're really the type that you know you
could probably read these books
gain the information probably be fine
you know you're you're mostly there and
then there's the people that are going
to come to you and you're like you know
you need to be in this
small program we can walk you through it
and then there's the people that it's
like
a reference yes so you're helping gauge
where they're at
yes so what you do though i think is
that
middle program where they're they're not
necessarily
you're not you're not referring them
because you're helping them so
it's and you're not telling them to take
the books home necessarily
you're helping them walk through this
small program that that
you know where you're saying is the best
bang for your buck program
so let's say i enroll in that program
it's eight weeks
yes and what's going to happen in those
eight weeks well it's a
it's a program that that has eight
sessions okay and so
uh the person comes once a week okay
so it's a once a week commitment of two
hours sounds doable
that sounds pretty doable and so in that
time they will get
uh a lecture on a specific topic and
it's usually the
various hit categories okay that we
address uh
give them the tools that they need to do
to turn some of those things around okay
and
they have some homework that they have
to go and do at home there's a workbook
that we work through
and then after the one hour lecture then
there's a small group session
okay where these things are discussed
and where
where the people work through the
workbook
together so to share some of the tools
yes because i think that's what you're
trying to find out that we have it's
very simple things like in
one of our first few sessions we go
through one
exercise right so when i went through
the program i tried to walk for an hour
each day because i discovered oh if i
walk for two hours each day
then i don't have to be on this
medication i'm on anymore and so i was
like i want to get off this stuff and i
actually weaned off the medication after
i finished the program
so exercise and walking uh is
is a very powerful way to do exercise or
interval
which is where um if let's say you're
not a runner you're just a walker you go
up a hill
fast for like 30 seconds or so and then
maybe a minute you do some walking
um that is really good for anxiety
um so exercise is a very beneficial
thing to do
mostly cardio because you want to get
the blood flowing
and the reason why is that it blood
flows and then it gets to the brain
which you need blood circulation in the
frontal lobe in order for you to
overcome your depression
another thing is a plant-based diet so
we actually have in the back of this
book there's recipes for people to
try out but i personally my small group
always recommends simple things we all
have a phone
so i recommend apps so there's the
documentary forks over nice
about a plant-based diet they have for
like five dollars to have an
app and they have so many recipes and
they keep updating them
so it's very affordable compared to an
actual cookbook that's maybe fifteen
dollars
and you just have on your phone so
that's another thing we do um
and then some other small thing is a
gratefulness journal now again
i'm a millennial so i use an app so
there's
i don't know if it's on android but on
the um on the iphone
there's an app called grateful and it
reminds you every single night at a
certain time that you set for yourself
hey it's time to journal and then all it
asks is it has different prompts like
what's something something nice somebody
said to you today what made you smile
today
because if you're so depressed and you
have a really bad day
you're not going to see anything good in
that day but then it you know we tell
people
um the sun was shining today isn't that
something to be grateful for or you woke
up today
you're breathing you have a spouse you
have children
um the fact that you came here you're in
this program that's something to be
grateful for
so we teach them to think like that um
and and there's a few more things in
there as well i like how this is
holistic
because it is you go back to the
exercise it's like well
not only does it help your mental health
we're all sitting around too much anyway
yeah right yeah i mean we need to get up
more anyway
yeah so you're killing multiple birds
with one stone by
saying yeah i'm going to go outside and
walk for an hour it's going to help my
mental health it's going to help my
physical health
you know and you know you're going to
compound the effects that are going on
so that's great yeah it's a
comprehensive program the more
things you implement the greater the
greater the effect yeah so it's going to
teach you also to
besides you know trying to eat as much
as possible on a plant-based diet
because
when you have cholesterol and a high fat
diet
clogging the arteries in your brain
that's when your brain is going to feel
depressed we all know that if you ate a
high-fat meal
you feel very sleepy and you just don't
feel good right
so and then the other thing is um like
incorporating ground flax seeds chia
seeds
those all are brain food it's nutrition
for the brain
it's omega-3 plant-based omega-3 no fish
that is very important to incorporate
that in your breakfast
and to have a good whole wheat type
of breakfast hopefully maybe even with a
hot cereal
and have your berries with that the
berries are some of the high antioxidant
um you know fruits and and you
then of course you want to incorporate
your green leaf ease so nutrition for
your brain
thinking and then hydration drinking
water
yeah your brain needs water right when
your brain is dehydrated
it is not functioning optimally if you
foggy and
so one thing i i i don't know how many
people know
but there's something called heart
disease we call it heart disease but
really what's happening is it's it's not
that
um cholesterol and hardening are out of
the arteries
only happens in your heart right right
it's actually a whole body
problem and so circulation is diminished
to
all of your body and i remember this is
a kind of a funny story
i took um as biochemistry and chemistry
major in college
and in my biochem 2 class i remember we
had to
uh study um
oh man what was that medication um
it's for male dysfunction uh male um
viagra and yeah so we're talking about
viagra and the reason is you know
they the guy goes to the doctor and he's
like you know hey things aren't working
properly and he you know thinks he needs
viagra
and the doctor it's like the first tip
off
to the doctor that well you're at risk
for heart disease
because you don't have proper blood flow
and circulation
to your whole body and yeah it's a
symptom but it's not it's not just
affecting that part of your body it's
affecting your whole body
so a lot of people don't know that so
i'd like to bring that up because
it's a whole body problem yeah it's you
know erectile dysfunction
uh it can be the first sign of heart
disease
but if if it's a sign of heart disease
it can also be a sign
of brain disease yeah okay because you
have poor circulation
to your brain as well yeah yep poor
circulation everywhere
so okay so we're learning all these
tips and tricks on how to
live better really live live more
healthfully
and it has this synergistic compound
effect
on our mental health as well so you're
gonna have these one-hour sessions these
these breakout sessions and they're you
know you're gonna talk through some
things you're gonna have them
things to implement in their their daily
life
then what well i just wanted to share a
story of a girl that came in our program
she's 24 years old
and a single mom she came to our program
when she came initially she was dressed
like a prostitute
and i i kind of felt a little
embarrassed because of the men that were
there
um but we are we just love everybody
non judgmentally and we just love
everyone unconditionally as they come
into the program it is a
faith-based program um and she had no
money
so i presented her case actually to our
church and our church said that they'd
be willing to sponsor her she wrote out
you know just some of her the you know
stuff that she was going through and the
church said we'll sponsor she was so
grateful
every week she would just absorb
everything and
implement it and after the first couple
of weeks her
after appearance her clothing just
started changing just becoming more
modest
um just dressing what we would consider
you know like an average person um but
she
incorporated everything she would sit in
the sunshine and take her
her books you know telling yourself the
truth that she'd be reading
and doing exercise she had a little
two-year-old
and she made a full recovery we actually
had her come into our residential
program
that we held in atlanta she came and
gave her testimony there she started
coming to church
she started taking bible studies she was
just an intention she was baptized
yeah she wasn't she she had her son
dedicated
she was actually baptized but she gave
her heart to christ yes absolutely
she made a full commitment to jesus
christ just a
complete turnaround and it was just so
beautiful to see
yeah that's awesome so it works it works
for people
i think we said on the last show it has
a 90 plus percent
you know rate as long as you're doing
the things that are outlined
so i have a couple questions so one what
are have you had anybody that
they have they need to come back and
repeat it
well you become an alumni of the program
and
i mean the information uh that is
presented
there's a lot of information i mean this
is a you know a fairly
hefty little book yeah and there's a lot
of information in there
and these are not the only materials
that are presented so
so it's there's a lot of the stuff that
you don't assimilate
the first time you go through it like
even telling yourself the truth
you need to read this book more than
once okay because
some of the topics uh we just teach you
about
nutrition this is good for you this is
good for you and we give you recipes and
stuff those are pretty straightforward
lectures and the small group discussions
is really
straightforward but then when we get
into the more deeper kind of things
you know things of how do you recognize
abnormal distorted thoughts
and how do you fix those kind of things
then it becomes a little bit more deeper
and you need to read more you need to
study more
and it takes a little longer and then
how do you deal with
with loss and things in your life and
the steps that you need to go through to
properly deal with that
those are more deeper kind of things
those sessions are usually a little bit
more emotionally
laden and people share more things
that's deep from their heart
and stuff and so yes many of them will
come through the program again
they will read the stuff over again and
then the second time they come through
you know more lights go on sure and they
they implement more things
and they get even better wow so so it's
exciting
so it's you're oh i'm sorry go ahead
it's okay that's one of the reasons why
to me it's a privilege and honor to be
facilitating this program to be working
with people through the program
because every time i go through the
program i learn something more
something more that i can implement in
my own life and
um i also just want to say that
counseling
with a christian counselor be very
careful that you go to a christian
council when you take counseling um but
counseling with a christian counselor
doing christian cbt
is very um it complements this program
very well
and i would highly recommend that so for
those that don't know don't have a frame
of reference you've mentioned
cbt not we didn't say cbd we said cbt
[Laughter]
what is that what is i mean it's an
acronym what does it stand for
and and what is that accomplishing okay
well
it's cognitive behavior therapy so it
really is thinking about
what am i thinking okay so it's
metacognition
so when we have that strong rise in
emotion that feeling
think about okay so what thoughts are
going through my mind right now
and what evidence do i have that this
thought is true and
for me the most important thing is what
is god's word say about this
how can i replace this unhealthy this
dysfunctional thought
with truth in god's word because
ultimately
i believe this is the only source of
truth that we have in
the world yeah so this is a fascinating
concept just from a spiritual
perspective
because sin entered the world because of
lies and so now we're saying if
if we want healing the way to healing
is the way of truth and so you have to
replace the lies
that are in your mind and we tell
ourselves i've read this book it's a
good book my wife
told me you need to read this book and
so we read read it together
um it's amazing how many lies we tell
ourselves
every day you know and and so we have to
replace those lies with
the truth to be healed it's a
fascinating concept you know it's like
we fell because of a lie the only way
out of that
is the truth the the danger about the
whole thing is as we live in a world of
lies
yeah so the media the movies the
the television the the computer screens
they all
lie to us okay so we've got all these
lies around us
but that's one thing but the more
dangerous lies
are the lies we tell ourselves because
they originate from negative
automatic negative thoughts that are not
true that have been instilled in our
brains
through our references and experiences
that we've had in our life
yeah you see and many of those things
are not true
but now what happens is firstly i think
that thought
so it's i'm activating my brain then
i'm speaking that thought out aloud
in the car while i'm driving you know
i've done something that's not
wise and i say to myself you're such an
idiot derek
what's wrong with you you see so not
only do i think i'm an idiot
i say i'm an idiot and then i year it
yeah
it's compounding so it compounds three
times you know
and the more you tell yourself these
negative things you know i can't do this
i'm an idiot i'm no use i'm no good or
whatever it may be
i'm worthless you know life's not worth
living the more you say those things the
more
so your self-talk becomes even more of a
danger than the stuff that's out there
well in the question to ask ourselves
right um john 8 verse 44 and the
scripture says that the devil
is a liar and the father of lies right
yeah
so if the devil appeared before you and
he told you
you are worthless would that be
more difficult to believe or if it goes
into your mind
yeah and tells you the lie i am
worthless
yeah i think that reframing as i also
call it yes
is one of the most powerful tools in
therapy
and what i like about it because that's
part of the cbt
is that you are being equipped with a
tool it's not like
that you're you're um attached to
therapists for the rest of your life
you know um you are actually being given
a tool
and you're retraining your thoughts so
like for example
what i one thing that that that i really
appreciate is the idea of um
um is there evidence for this so like
you might be thinking
uh fortune telling you might be like and
this and this this is all gonna happen
but it's like is there any evidence for
that right now if you really think back
to us like no there isn't evidence is it
possible
yeah is there evidence right now no and
that um
with that i mean it completely changes
people when they have a different
perspective
and it lowers their anxiety because the
anxiety is there because they truly
believe it's going to happen but there's
zero evidence that it's going to happen
right so cbt what you're saying is so
true cbt
actually you're not attached to this
counselor
cbt is the process of you becoming
your own counselor your own therapist
your own therapist because you begin to
recognize
your own distorted thoughts and then
challenging those thoughts are they true
where do they come from who put them
there
and scratching them out the ones that
and scratch them until they're destroyed
and so you actually you can actually
change
your brain by using your mind right
that's awesome you see yeah so that's
exciting it's incredible yeah so one of
the things
one of the sessions that we have in this
um
little workbook and that we follow on
cognitive behavior therapy
and that nedley program has written is
looking at the cognitive distortions
like for example all or nothing thinking
you know like
you know um if i ate one size of cake
today
i've already broken my diet so i may as
well just go and eat it okay
yeah right you know already nobody loves
me
right yeah yeah or i i already messed up
on this day
so you know mesologists and then over
generalization you know
um you're always late
that's what it said yeah you're always
late
yeah mental filter mind reading
yes having a mental filter like having
just a very pessimistic
mental filter and seeing everything
through this negative view
you know we sometimes even treat people
that way
we if we have a negative belief about
someone well you know women
are just highly emotional you know
they're not
rational beings so you know you can't
reason with a woman you know or or
a woman might think you know men just
have no feelings you know they're just
not
you know they're not loving or something
like that then you see
those people through that mental filter
which
it's a tragedy because then if that
person comes like even if you have a
negative mental filter about your
neighbor
and you think well this neighbor is just
such a mean person
then even the morning when he comes past
you your house and
he weighs it you say hi good morning you
think oh he's so manipulative what's he
trying to manipulate now
or another one fortune telling you know
it says i will never be able to overcome
this problem and that
sometimes even if you keep saying that
yourself over and over
you're going to adjust your behavior
according to your beliefs
and it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy you're like see but it's like
but it's
always has to do with your behavior and
your thought process
and then mind reading you know it's so
easy
to think you know just look at someone's
facial expression or
you know some aspect of their behavior
and then just well you know i can just
see that this is what they're planning
or this is what they you know in the
meantime that's a cognitive distortion
no we cannot read other people's minds
and
you know we need to rather believe the
best about someone
instead of you know having a negative
view of them
and and believing the worst rather let's
believe the very best about the person
until we're proved wrong until they've
said something or actually
done something you know so i can really
see how
people fall into um
things like the secret because
you know it's like believing something
you know if you believe it it'll be so
and i can see like there's a there's a
bit of a fine line but what i like is
the distinction of where are you getting
the truthful information
you know has to be rooted in the word of
god right it's not just so because i
think it's so it's so because god says
it's so
yeah and so you have to be careful that
you don't fall into that
ditch i could see how easily it would be
to
you know to fall into new age thinking
if you took the idea without the word of
god
yeah which sadly is creeping into the
church the law of attraction a lot of
the big mega churches that you see on
tv and stuff uh man it's right it's very
deceptive when they're like
you are created in the image of god and
when god spoke things happen so
therefore when you speak
you have his power to make things happen
it's like that doesn't make sense oh
yeah
it's dangerous well and one of these
cognitive distortions
picking up on what you said is emotional
reasoning
because i feel it then it is that way
right
and also follow your heart you know
whatever you feel
that must be right i've heard that
before yeah we have to be very careful
to base our decisions on
emotions because our emotions can lie to
us you know emotions are not a safeguard
and
how often have we have something happen
to us and we're very emotional
and then we make a foolish decision and
later i'm like we're done with it we're
over like ben
if i only had just waited to make an
important decision when i was not
emotional
right that's true it happens right so so
the program really has when you're
looking from a treatment point of view
has two legs okay the the first leg
is using all these lifestyle
interventions
to improve circulation okay and like
we've already discussed
circulation everywhere it's not just to
the brain to the heart to the lungs and
the eyes
everywhere and so the better we get
frontal low blood flow
the more our mind and our and our
reasoning and our understanding is
switched on
and then your second leg or arm of
treatment is
the cognitive behavioral therapy or cbt
where
we you are taught given the tools to to
use
to recognize distorted thoughts to
rectify those
to re destroy the old ones replace them
with new ones
that takes time that takes effort and
some people it's it's recommended that
you probably need
about 20 hours of cognitive behavioral
therapy
to reinforce and to re and to establish
a permanent change
that you can take on and those are
really the two
the two things that makes this program
successful
awesome yeah okay so
eight-week program but like we learned
it doesn't really end after eight weeks
no it's actually it's a
lifeline it's a longer yeah of learning
and recognizing and practicing and
you know changing as you learn
and improve so just this is actually
yeah not a depression and anxiety
recovery program
it's actually a brain enhancing program
here
out of curiosity if anybody else is
wondering is there a like a zoom
meeting for this or is there any kind of
videos or audio book or
are there any other options we sometimes
do do a zoom
option and this fall we'll be running a
program that will have in person as well
as zoom option
and on the zoom we can pretty much take
unlimited number of people
um yeah the zoom option is very nice we
do the small group session then over
zoom
but we also always like to have the in
person
yeah i would encourage in person but if
somebody can't get out of their house or
maybe you're you know covered or
whatever cool
yeah okay sounds like an awesome program
yeah
so any other success stories or i mean
have you do you know of anybody that you
know they
did this 20 years ago and been fine ever
since or anything like that
you guys want to share long-term success
well um
when we were at the emotional
intelligence summit uh dr nedley had
um a man there who had actually become
homeless he was a a pilot a commercial
airline pilot
and um he went through some depression
he started making some mistakes as a
pilot and they
cut his job they fired him and then
um his wife divorced him at that point
and he became homeless wow talk about
everything
falling at once talk about losses
and at that point a family member said
to him we will pay for you
to go through the nearly depression
anxiety residential program
he came through the program he made a
full recovery and
it was two years later he was flying on
united airlines again
that's impressive you got his job back
yeah i mean that is you
same airline all right same american
same airline there you go yeah
they hired him back yeah and then this
other girl that this is my first program
that i helped out with she was a
college age girl um was married
and um i shared this earlier or
either i shared in here or the last
episode i don't remember but
um about when she came in that i greeted
her and i was like hey
how are you doing and wouldn't look me
in the eye
she had no emotion in her eyes and she
shook my hand and her hand was like this
like it was like a dead fish in my hand
and i thought oh boy
this is a bad situation um and
yeah so she went through the program and
you could tell the first couple of
sessions just looked down and you know
really close to committing suicide to
the point now
where she is a missionary somewhere
completely recovered
um going back to school doing a master's
degree
so to look at that within eight weeks
how someone can go from i'm going to
commit suicide
to i'm a happy person and i'm smiling
and i'm enjoying life
it's really powerful like you mentioned
earlier we
we can all reach these places in our
mind a physical or a mental state where
you would make a harsh
or some kind of you would react a
certain way you wouldn't normally react
right same thing could happen with
suicide i mean you're going through
my my girlfriend left me or whatever
you'll get over it it's a grieving
period but in that time
you may make a harsh reaction and
and go through with suicide so if
somebody can be with you
walk you through that hard time and let
you realize look this
this will pass you know i'll i'll share
just one quick
uh person as well and the reason why i'm
sharing this one as well
is because you know for people who feel
when you have to
accomplish something and you feel
there's a wall and
i can't do this to show you that
that no mountain is too high or no hill
is too big for you to climb over
and so this is a guy that also came to
the
residential program that we held in
atlanta he was a pilot
so he's no dumbo uh you know he's
he's flying and stuff and so he wanted
to upgrade
his uh pilot license to flying jet
aircraft and so he needed to do some
training obviously and some
and he was going through depression i
believe there were some issues in his
family life and things as well that that
brought some of that stuff
on and uh but he just had a brain fog
he couldn't he couldn't focus he
actually wrote the exam
a few times a few times and failed and
so some of these instructors then said
to him listen
you need to really get this thing sorted
out because this doesn't look good on
your resume
you know i've i've passed or i'm gonna
pass but i've tried it three or four or
five times
so they actually suggested to him not to
write the exam because it doesn't look
good
when he keeps on failing and he was
getting really frustrated because
he wants to do this this is his job he
wants to
advance in his job and he felt this
brain fog that he couldn't see through
came to the program did all the things
made a full recovery
passed this exam and he's flying his jet
aircraft
you see so if a guy like that can get
through that and these are not
these are not easy exams i mean these
are these are significant exams to to
get through they're very strict
and if you can make it if you can clear
your brain up
so you can think clearly and you can get
over your depression and your anxiety
you know there's life you can go on to
be you can go pile you can be a jet
pilot you can do whatever yes that's
amazing sky's the limit yes
there's a girl that was very suicidal
she was
17 at the time and just went through a
really really really bad experience
um relationship wise and um you know
ended up trying to commit suicide she
drank
so many poles and everything they and
this boyfriend of hers took her to
mexico
and she was actually abandoned in the
hospital
because he then just took off and she
was suicidal because he was cheating on
her
and so an aunt of hers her parents
didn't have passports and her
entrepreneurs flew out and helped her to
be able to come back um and then she
came through the program
her name is michaela i can share her
name because she shares her testimony
openly and she made a full recovery
she's now a nurse practitioner
oh wow yeah it's incredible
it's amazing just amazing amazing stuff
yeah where people when they
overcome they can go on to help other
people
you know you're helping in this program
and uh missionaries and
nursing and what would happen if you
would have committed that suicide
all the people that you wouldn't have
been able to help and bring happiness
and joy to right one of the nurses
the first program that we ran in atlanta
was dr nedley and
of course um the nurse
in our program her name is christine i
can also share her name because she
um um she shares her testimony
anyway and she had like i believe it was
five suicide attempts
one of which she had gone through a very
bad divorce
and she was very depressed she had a
little boy and i asked her about it she
said all i could think was that my son
will be better off without me oh my god
wow
and so like she walked into the woods
with a gun to her head and
pull the trigger but by god's grace
nobody knows why that never went off
but um and she ended up then going to a
motel
and um taking fentanyl and
um nobody knew where she was not her
parents nobody knew where she was
and she thought that she would die and
um three days later she woke up on the
same side
still lying in the same position but
praise god she woke up
and her parents at that point convinced
her to come to the
weimar residential program and
for the first seven days she was trying
to leave the program
all the time they had a hard time
keeping her there but after seven days
she started cooperating with that
program and dr nealy kept her there a
couple more weeks
but she's an intensive care nurse now
she has like a ministry she shares her
testimony
and she's a blessing she is one of the
nurses in this program
and that's testimony to us to to really
um
be persistent with your friends and your
family because
that lady was she was basically left for
dead
if it wasn't for her friends and family
how easily
we label those people as losers yeah
as a loser and they're actually so
strong yeah but
actually actually they can make a full
turnaround and change their life and
and god uses the lowest moments in
people's lives
to glorify his name and god uses it as a
ministry yeah
that testimony was just something help
somebody else
yes a really simple acronym that we
often talk about is new start
okay and this applies to both mental
health and physical health it stands for
nutrition
so a plant-based whole food plant-based
diet to avoid your vegan snacks and
sugar and all that kind of stuff and
especially high cholesterol and high
sugar is really bad for the brain so you
want to avoid that
um so new start nutrition
exercise you know try to walk as much as
possible during lunch break just go for
an hour-long walk
um water intake that's a water it's both
water intake so you want to look up on
the internet
how much water do i need for my weight
because that's the first
difference per person and then what i do
this is what i teach my people
when i do the small group is i have this
one bottle of nalgene i
know how much is in this nalgene and so
i know i need two and a half of these
each day
so i wake up in the morning i drink
water and i finish this before my lunch
break i finished the second one after my
lunch break
in the afternoon and a half in the
evening so i know
oh it's cutting close to my lunch break
i need to drink some more it helps so
much
also hydrotherapy which means contrast
showers so i believe it's three to five
minutes
a hot as hot as you can handle 30
seconds cold
three minutes hot 30 seconds cold three
minutes hot
30 seconds cold and if you can you want
to rest lie down for 20 minutes
if not i mean whatever you can do right
and that's going to improve your blood
circulation
um then you have to ask for sunlight
so just being outside if you go for a
walk you got sunlight
you got exercise and you got fresh air
because the a
stands for air so then you got t
for temperance which means you know you
don't over eat
and you're careful with maybe your media
intake those kind of things
you start there you go
uh rest so air fresh air open crack your
window
i even in the middle of winter i crack
all of my windows
and i rather put a few more blankets on
when i sleep then i have any fresh air i
crack the window in my office or if you
go for a walk for example
um and then rest get enough sleep get
eight eight hours or so of sleep every
single day
set a time for yourself saying eight
o'clock nine o'clock whatever 10 o'clock
i'm going to go to bed and then um
trusting god
is the most important aspect is
restoring your relationship with god
if you get those straight um then you're
going to
be successful and i want to share one
more thing with it when it comes to
nutrition because you talked about
things like you need to eat omega-3
which is so important for the brain
and so i have a simple recipe you take
two tablespoons of chia seeds
two tablespoons of flax and two
tablespoons of hemp hearts and now you
want to
you want to ground up the flax so that
your body can absorb it so what i do is
i throw it all together in my coffee
grinder
i don't drink coffee i just use it for
that and then i grind grind
ground it up and then i take two
tablespoons of that
every single day until i finish it and i
throw it in some cereal every morning
and in my cereal my healthy cereal not
your sugary cereal at walmart but like
your healthier granola
i throw in um
i'm blanking right now pumpkin seeds
there you go pumpkin seeds
sunflower seeds almonds walnuts
every day and just that even just one of
these aspects we talked about today
exercise water whatever
will boost your brain so much and so you
eat it every day and you avoid your
omega-3s from your
fish because that contains mercury which
can cause depression
and that is going to give you a major
boost and it's so simple i know i'm
sitting here thinking i'm like
this what you're saying sounds so simple
sounds like something that
everyone should have in their life every
day but
there's something changing in our
society most of us are sitting inside
sitting at a computer eating junk food
not drinking enough water
drinking sodas and stuff but it's like
wow 100 years ago that
this was probably less of an issue and
like you guys are saying we're seeing
more mental health problems come out so
and i just want to say that this program
boosts your immune system which is great
for preventing coverage
and you're also getting better if you do
have a flu or the coverage or any
lifestyle related disease for that
matter
yeah so um but i just wanted to expand a
little bit on the trust in god
portion because that is so critical and
i want to turn here
in the scripture to hebrews chapter 2
um and verse 14 it says
since all of these sons and daughters
have flesh and blood
jesus took on flesh and blood to be
like them he did this so that by dying
he would destroy the one who had power
over death
that is the devil in this way he would
free
those who were slaves all their lives
because they were afraid of dying
therefore he has to become like he had
to become like his brothers and sisters
so that he could be merciful he became
like them so that he could serve as a
faithful chief priest
in god's presence and make peace with
god
for their sins because jesus experienced
temptation when he suffered
he is able to help others when they are
tempted
and jesus went through whatever
we are going through we can look at the
life of jesus he went through that he
was betrayed
by a kiss he when he was hanging on the
cross he was tempted
to not forgive those who were betraying
him and abusing him he was tempted to
take control of the situation
to fight back and protect himself and he
was abused by the
priests and and by people in power over
him and should have been protecting him
physically and well he relates to our
abuse physically and sexually because he
was stripped naked
that's right and emotionally and
emotionally and emotionally
yes and so jesus feels
our suffering and he identifies with us
in our suffering
and he is a faithful high priest in
heaven right now
for us he was tempted on all points like
as we are
yet without sin and so to come to jesus
you know to read in the gospels the
first starting with the book of john
and then the book of matthew and mark
and luke
and to really you know come face to face
with jesus
who took our suffering on him so that he
can identify with us and that our story
can identify with jesus story that
to me there's so much healing in
in that yeah and we highly recommend if
you want to show it the book by
um paul connect of course yeah the
hidden half of the gospel
where this is talked about and it had a
huge impact on my life as well if you're
struggling with your relationship with
jesus or god
this is a great book to start off with
yes i highly recommend this book
where do you get it um go to
hiddenhalf.org
okay um or straight to the heart um
available like on amazon or anything
like that it might be on amazon
i think i think it's available on amazon
as well okay but the hidden half of the
gospel saying that
you know we often talk about how jesus
died for our sins
but the hidden half of the gospel is
that jesus took our suffering
and that by his stripes the bible says
by his stripes we are healed
amen all right well there you have it
you are
not alone that's right there is someone
who can identify with
each and every one of us on this planet
and that is jesus and i really liked how
you
brought out that encouragement in the
end and
the other thing i like hearing about
this program is you know there we talked
about in the last one there's there's
hope
but you can see that people can recover
from all these things that are
afflicting us and
with simple steps easy steps and in a
short amount of time
in fact the whole program that you were
just talking about
is less time than many of those
medications that people are
on actually take effect after
you could be on zoloft or prozac or
something and it might be three months
before you see the effect you could be
done in two
using simple lifestyle changes
and simple therapy using the word of god
and recover from something like
depression
and anxiety so what many people don't
realize that when you start on that
medication
it actually has a black box warning that
it increases impulsivity
and so especially young people you know
who
you know the frontal lobe of the brain
is not mature until we're 30.
so young people are more at risk for
that impulsivity
and when we start on those um
antidepressant medications
there's actually a higher risk for
impulsivity and for suicidality so wow
um as we're closing we share the link to
where people can get in contact with you
guys in your ministry
yes um dr halzinger.com
and natalie depression
ladydepressionrecovery.com
and then depression the way out is for
the
uh the name of the residential program
all right
great resources and if you missed the
last program and if
there is media playing a role in your
life that it can
that can actually contribute to these
kind of things two documentaries that we
recommend
are pseudology and hashtag selfie
one is about the general science of what
happens in your brain the other is more
focused on social media we encourage you
to check those out
so thank you all for joining us and
thank you for joining us and walking us
through
what this recovery looks like and how
there can be hope and healing at the end
of the day
thank you all for watching and we will
see you next time on led live
[Music]
i love anime i love it i mean
i can't watch enough of this the duelist
who they say can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern from parents the
death note is derived from a japanese
animated show the girl told authorities
she got the idea from a cartoon network
show
mom satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
um
visit our brothers at school for
prophets dot tv and watch from babylon
to america which has over 5 million
views on youtube alone and follow it up
with america
2 babylon check the description below
for links to this and more
[Music]
you